مكونات اتجهت ارادتها نحو الهدنه بعد
اقتتال خلف المئات من الضحايا والمصابين
اتفاق اطاري للتعيش السلمي يمهد الطريقه
لمؤتمر جامع للصلح بين القبائل الاتفاق هو
خارطه الطريق
لوقف العدائيات وهو بيكون ملزم للفراق او
للطرفين انهم ااا يوقفوا
الاغتسال فيما بينهم
يتم تماره بواسطه الوزراء حكومه تقريبا
لتصبح اقليم النيل الازرق اول منطقه يتم
فيها اصدار
ويدخل المتنازعين في هدنه الا ان المخاوف
من عدم صموده بددتها ضمانات الرد الحاسب
الذي تعهدت به القوه المسلحه
اهميه ما جرى اليوم يكمن في
الاتفاق على هدنه محروسه بالقوات المسلحه
وبي الحركه والجيش الشعبي وكل المكونات
الامنيه وانها ستتعامل بحسب ااا مع هذه
الهدنه الامنيه بالتالي انا اعتقد ان
هنالك فرصه كبيره في الايام القادمه
للوصول لاتفاق اذا ينفتح المشهد في
الاقليم الاستراتيجي والمحادي لدوله جنوب
السودان واثيوبيا على واقع جديد اثر
المصالحات بين مكوناته الاجتماعيه بعد
اغتال كاد ان يعصف بامني واستقراري
المنطقه باسرها محمد عثمان العربيه اقليم
النيل الازرق مدينه التمازين